♪ ♪ ♪
- Donc, aujourd'hui,
on va travailler avec Fancy.
Donc, Fancy a 15 ans.
- C'est une première rencontre,
pour Renée Bertrand.
- Bonjour.
- Ok, c'est correct. Oui!
RENÉE BERTRAND, vétérane,
Forces armées canadiennes
- Quand on brosse heheheval,
ça relaxe son système nerveux,
c'est un petit peu comme
un massage, pour elle.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et c'est a c c cet apaisement
que Renée vient chercher.
- Le brossage de cheval, c'est
un exercice de pleine présence
qui nous permet de s'approcher
du cheval, mais également d'être
plus présent avec notre propre
corps.
Est-ce que ton système nerveux
est calme assez pour monter
ce matin?
- Oui.
- Parfait!
♪ ♪ ♪
En thérapie normale, on passe
beaucoup de temps à parler de
nos pensées et de nos émotions.
- J'étais technicienne médicale
dans les Forces armées
canadiennes pendant un petit peu
plus de 19 ans. Et puis, j'ai
été en mission en Afghanistan
en 2004, à Kaboul. J'étais
affectée dans une clinique
médicale, au camp Julien.
Et puis, on recevait des
patients de n'importe quelle
nationalité qui avaient affaire
à être là, qui voulaien
des soins.
♪ ♪ ♪
J'ai été libérée médicalement
pour blessure physique, durant
mon service, et puis quand s s s
plus qui j'étais, j'étais
perdue, je savais pas ce qui
se passait avec moi,
je me sentais mal...
- C'est là que la recherche
d'une thérapie a commencé.
Le ranch de Caroline LeBlanc
lui a vite été r
Ici, les trois quarts des
clients sont des vétérans
ou des premiers répondants.
CAROLINE LeBLANC, psychologue
- Le cheououououououjours
le danger, donc il est dans
un état d'hypervigilance.
Et puis, nos clients
qui souffrent de stress
post-traumatique sont toujours
dans des états d'hypervigilance.
Donc, quand ils rencontrent
le cheval, le cheval veut
être en état de calme,
donc pour être en état de calme,
le client doit se calmer
également.
- C'est dur à expliquer en mots
pour quelqu'un qui ne l'a jamais
vécu. La connexion qu'on fait
avec les chevaux, c'est pas
juste une connexion, c'est aussi
une relation. Et puis,
au travers de ça, on apprend
à guérir et on apprend
à se connaître, aussi.
- Une connexion particuliè
pertinente présentement,
alors que les images
de la guerre en Ukraine
ravivent des traumatismes.
(sirène d'alerte)
- Entendre les alarmes
à la bombe, on n'a pas besoin
de les entendre, à la télé,
mais comme voir les flashs
et tout ça, tu le sais que
le son est là, puis tu l'entends
dans ta tête.
- Ça te ramène à Kaboul.
- Ça ramène des "triggers", là,
c'est ça.
- Depuis l'Afghanistan, j'ai pas
vu encore cette réaction-là.
Donc, on remarque une grosse
différence chez nos clients.
- Ça ébranle tout le monde?
- Ça ébranle tout le monde,
exactement.
- Ma première réaction était :
OK, quand est-ce qu'on part?
Ça, c'est liqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqique
qui embarque. C'est : OK,
je veux aller... je veux
y aller, je sais quoi faire,
c'est un monde que je connais,
c'est e e e e e e e e e je sais
faire. Ce n'est pas
nécessairement la bonne
réaction, peut-être, à avoir.
- Et ça, l'équithérapie
est là pour lui rappeler.
- Pour "focusser" sur ma
guérison, le cheval m'aide
à rester ici, rester présente
mentalement ici.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Tu te sens loin des scènes
de combat, là?
- Je me sens loin c c c c c c c.
C'est ce que je veux.
C'est ça...
♪ ♪ ♪